دعنا نحصل على بعض التحليلات حول الموقف
مع العقيد المتقاعد سيدريك لايتون سي إن إن
المحلل العسكري وعضو سابق
في هيئة الأركان المشتركة في البنتاغون
ما هو
تقييمك للوضع الآن سيدريك ويل بريانا إنه
وضع سيء حقًا بالنسبة للأوكرانيين
عندما تنظر إلى  الخريطة هنا
ألقِ نظرة وسترى
كييف هنا بالطبع في
الجزء الشمالي الأوسط من البلاد ،
وأعتقد هنا أنه أحد
الأهداف الرئيسية للجهود الروسية
لأن ما سيفعلونه هو
"  سوف ينزلون إلى هنا من
بيلاروسيا
وهم يذهبون أيضًا عبر البلجيكية
البلجيكية إلى خاركيف
حيث كان سام في سام كايلي كان في
ما يحدث هنا هل
سمعنا انفجارات
في أوديسا وحقيقة أن هذه
الانفجارات حدثت هناك تشير
أنه من المحتمل أن يكون هناك
جهد ضربة صاروخية محمولة في البحر أه من
البحر الأسود ، لذا مع كل هذا
ما تراه هو في الأساس
هجوم ثلاثي الشعب
ليس فقط للاستيلاء على ميناء كبير  أيون من
أوكرانيا ولكن من المحتمل أن يقسم
البلد إلى نصفين ،
هل هناك نمط على الإطلاق
تراه هنا وكم هو أكثر
مما كنت تتوقعه جيدًا ، لقد
توقعت بالفعل
أن يتقدموا بشكل كبير.
تحدث الكثير من الناس في
الغرب أه لم تكن الطريقة التي سيفعلها بوتين
، لذا توقعت منهم أن يفعلوا ذلك
الآن عندما تنظر إلى المناطق المختلفة
التي أطلقوا فيها
التفجيرات بالفعل ، والتي تعرف أساسًا
أنك تنظر إليها  شيء ما في جميع
أنحاء البلاد ،
لذا توضح كل نقطة هنا أن
هناك نوعًا من الجهد
الذي بذله الروس لاستهداف كل
هذه الكيانات المختلفة وهذا
يوضح حقًا مدى صعوبة عملية التخطيط
بالنسبة لهم ، ولكنها كانت أيضًا
عملية تخطيط شاملة للغاية
لذلك ذكرت أوديسا
ويبدو أن هناك نظامًا صاروخيًا بحريًا
أه كان
سيُستخدم هناك ، هل يمكنك إخبارنا
بالمزيد قليلاً عن هذا
بالتأكيد ما أه ماذا يفعلون  من الناحية المنطقية لديها
أه في بعض السفن البحرية الروسية
لديها صواريخ كروز
أه التي هي
أساسًا صواريخ أه
سطح - أرض التي
ولدت في السفن وما يفعلونه هو أنهم
يستهدفون مناطق فيك تعرف على
السواحل يمكنهم أيضًا استخدام  نفس
النوع من الصواريخ
لملاحقة الماريوبول أه وسمعنا
انفجارات هناك تقارير عن
انفجارات هناك أه لذا فهذه
الأنظمة الصاروخية هي جزء من مخزون البحرية الروسية
وهي أيضًا
شيء شائع جدًا لاستخدامها في هذه الأنواع من
العمليات  نحن نستخدمها من جانبنا ،
فالروس لديهم بعض
صواريخهم أقدم قليلاً من صواريخنا ولكن
مع ذلك
عندما يأتون من بعدك ، لا
يهم نوع الصاروخ فهو
لا يزال سيئًا ولا يزال يشكل خطرًا
عليك